This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn.
这是一档由I-Heart制作的播客。百分之百真人。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？欢迎收听由你最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人凯尔·盖姆（Kear Games）主持的《艰难成长》（Learn the Hard Way）。这个空间探讨的是黑男性的经历，进行在任何其他地方都绝对不安全进行的诚实对话，但你是在与一位懂行的持证专业人士进行对话。有多少男人穿着一套隐形的铠甲。它向世界发出信号：你可不是好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要这样做，收听学习。
the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice in so much, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Gillespie and Michael Mancini.
用艰难的方式，在AHA电台APP、苹果播客或任何你收听播客的地方。2023年，单身汉明星克莱顿·埃克德（Clayton Eckerd）被指控生下双胞胎。但这次怀孕似乎是个骗局。你曾两次伪造了这个特定的测试，对吗？我伪造了一次测试。这需要一大批互联网侦探来揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格·吉莱斯皮（Greg Gillespie）和迈克尔·曼奇尼（Michael Mancini）。
My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available.
我惊呆了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨（Stephanie Young）。这是《深陷爱河》（Love Trapped）。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯（Laura Owens）终于面临了后果。在iHeart Radio App、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《深陷爱河》播客。2%。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人的比例。
I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWA% on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology. Hello, welcome new listeners, old listeners, first timers, whoever you are, so excited
我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter）。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析我们这个奇异的现代世界中，心理坚韧、健身和培养韧性的科学。经历一些艰难困苦，你将在另一端成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的自己。收听《2%》。也就是在iHeartRadio App、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方输入TWA%。你好，欢迎回到《你二十岁的心理学》，在这个播客中，我们将探讨二十岁时的一些重大生活改变和转折，以及它们对我们心理的意义。你好，欢迎新听众、老听众、初次听众，无论你是谁，都非常高兴
to have you here on the podcast, talking about some very exciting, fun, relevant topics today. Something that I really wanted to cover for a while and that feels particularly relevant because I obviously haven't posted for a hot minute, maybe like a couple of weeks. For this very reason, I've been absolutely swamped with my actual job, my real job, hence the motivation, the inspiration to talk about hustle culture and burnout on this episode. But before we get to that topic and to all the psychology behind it, I just want to update everyone about a new feature that this podcast has. So in, I don't know, the last few weeks, we have gained so many new listeners.
你能来到这个播客，今天我们来聊聊一些非常令人兴奋、有趣且贴近现实的话题。这是我一直想探讨的事情，而且感觉特别应景，因为我显然有一段时间没发动态了，大概有几周吧。正是因为这个原因，我被我的实际工作、我的真正工作给彻底淹没了，因此我才有了动力和灵感，在本期节目中来谈谈内卷文化（hustle culture）和职业倦怠（burnout）。但在我们进入这个话题以及其背后的所有心理学之前，我只想向大家更新一下这个播客的一个新功能。所以，在过去的几周里，我不知道，我们迎来了如此多的新听众。
So welcome to you all if you've just started listening in. And I thought it would be a really amazing time to start publishing some more personal and paid content. Mainly some of my guest episodes, my Let's Get Friendly segment, where I chat to some of my friends, other people I know in their 20s, just about their life experiences. the struggles and situations they're finding themselves in, some of my Loveline episodes where we answer love queries and questions and conundrums that you guys send in. So a lot of that content now I'm hoping to put out once of twice a month and I now have paid subscriptions, which is super exciting.
所以，如果你们刚刚开始收听，欢迎大家。我觉得现在是一个非常棒的时机，可以开始发布一些更具个人色彩和付费内容了。主要是我的嘉宾访谈节目，也就是我的“变友好”（Let's Get Friendly）环节，在这个环节中，我和一些朋友、我认识的处于二十多岁的人聊天，专门聊聊他们的生活经验。他们发现自己陷入的挣扎和处境，还有我的一些“爱情热线”（Loveline）节目，我们在其中回答你们发来的爱情疑问、问题和难题。所以我希望现在每个月推出一到两次这样的内容，而且我开通了付费订阅，这超级令人兴奋。
So if you feel called to, you can sign up for that on Spotify, if that's where you're listening, on Apple Podcasts, wherever you get your podcast, super excited to be kind of moving into that new stage of the podcast and being able to offer some more interesting and niche and personal content to those who are frequent listeners. So thank you for all the support so far and for those who have already subscribed in that capacity, obviously still putting out the regular episodes that you can listen to at your leisure. But for people who are wanting to hear some more of that stuff, please feel free to subscribe and thank you for all of the support so far. Anyhow, with that aside, this week,
所以，如果你有这种感觉，你可以在Spotify（如果你在那上面收听的话）、苹果播客，或者你获取播客的任何地方注册。我非常高兴能够进入播客的这个新阶段，并能够为经常收听的听众提供更多有趣、小众和个性化的内容。所以感谢大家一直以来的支持，也感谢那些已经以这种身份订阅的人，当然，我依然会定期发布常规节目，供大家在闲暇时收听。但对于那些想要听到更多这类内容的人，请随时订阅，并感谢大家至今为止的所有支持。好了，闲话少说，本周，
we are talking about a highly requested topic that I get on Instagram all the time. We are talking about hustle culture and we're talking about burnout. The two often go hand in hand and have super important ties to psychology and surprise surprise our 20s. So our main topic of the day is hustle culture. This is a term that I think has come about pretty recently, and I'm sure we've all encountered it in some capacity. Perhaps, I don't know, you've seen it talked about on TikTok or Instagram on your 4U page, especially if you're in the corporate lifestyle or on that pathway.
我们正在探讨一个在Instagram上经常被强烈要求的话题。我们要聊的是内卷文化（hustle culture），我们还要聊聊职业倦怠（burnout）。这两者通常密不可分，并且与心理学以及——不出所料——我们二十多岁的年龄有着超级重要的联系。所以我们今天的主题是内卷文化。这是一个我认为最近才出现的词，我相信我们所有人都曾以某种方式遇到过它。也许，我不知道，你在TikTok或Instagram的“为你推荐”（4U）页面上看到过关于它的讨论，尤其是如果你身处企业生活或走在那条道路上的话。
You've heard about it amongst friends. If you haven't heard about it, think phrases like rise and grand, and people are constantly talking about, almost bragging about their long hours and relentless schedule, It is super common, I think, in our 20s and in the early stages of our careers to really be like striving and aiming for a work-life balance that is more centred on work and success and gaining money and status and promotions and all of those kinds of things. I think I am definitely at fault of buying into hustle culture and I'm trying to be more conscious of how this lifestyle, and this image and almost this kind of philosophy has become indoctrinated into my own mind and my working habits and patterns hence this episode. And we're also going to be talking about burnout. Burnout is kind of a separate thing, I think, in many ways, but there are heaps of links.
你一定从朋友那里听说过它。如果你没听说过，想想“起早贪黑”（rise and grand）这样的词组，人们经常谈论甚至吹嘘自己超长的工作时间和不间断的日程安排。我认为这在我们的二十多岁以及职业生涯的早期非常普遍，我们总是努力去追求一种以工作、成功、金钱、地位、晋升以及所有这类事情为中心的职场生活平衡。我想我绝对犯了盲目跟风内卷文化的错误，我正试图更加清醒地认识到这种生活方式、这种形象、甚至这种哲学是如何渗入我自己的思维以及我的工作习惯和模式中的，因此才有了这一集。我们还将讨论职业倦怠。我认为在很多方面，职业倦怠是一个相对独立的话题，但它们之间有着千丝万缕的联系。
And I think that you don't need to be buying into hustle culture to be experiencing burnout. And maybe you're someone who's working super hard in a crunch period. work but you might not necessarily be burnt out but I thought that they really did go hand in hand and complimented each other quite well for this episode we're going to be talking about a bunch of things we're going to be talking about why hustle culture and um you know the expansion of our working hours beyond the nine to five and you know passive income and trying to you know seek promotion and that work heavy lifestyle has become so much more, I don't want to say popular, but so much more common for people in their 20s,
而且我认为你并不需要盲目跟风内卷文化才会经历职业倦怠。也许你是一个在冲刺阶段非常努力工作的人，但你可能不一定处于职业倦怠状态，但我认为它们确实紧密相连，并且为本期节目做了很好的互补。在本期节目中，我们将讨论很多事情，我们将讨论为什么内卷文化以及呃，你知道的，我们超越朝九晚五的工作时间的扩展，以及（你知道的）被动收入，试图（你知道的）寻求晋升，以及那种以工作为主的生活方式变得如此普遍——我不想说受欢迎，而是对二十多岁的人来说如此常见，
and who benefits from that, what the impact of that has been on society and culture and on an individual level around our mental health. And that's where burnout comes in. That is a really interesting relationship to me, and I'm going to be talking about what the impacts of, you know, long-term cortisol levels and long-term stress and long hours and a lack of sleep does to our body and does to our minds and our well-being and why it's important to have aspirations beyond financial and career success in our 20s. It's so critical for our long-term development, especially in our form of years, to achieve a healthy work-life balance and to center ourselves on what we really want in the future because this is where our patterns and our
以及谁从中受益，这对社会、文化以及围绕我们心理健康的个人层面产生了什么影响。这就是职业倦怠切入的地方。对我来说，这是一种非常有趣的联系，我将探讨长期皮质醇水平、长期压力、超长工作时间和缺乏睡眠对我们的身体、心智以及福祉造成了什么影响，以及为什么在二十多岁时，拥有超越金钱和职业成功的抱负是如此重要。对于我们的长期发展，特别是在我们的形成期，实现健康的工作与生活平衡，并将我们的中心放在我们对未来的真正渴望上，是至关重要的，因为正是在这里，我们对生活的模式和期望才开始形成和塑造。所以这超级有趣，非常切合实际，如果这些话题最近一直萦绕在你的脑海中，就像一直在我的脑海中一样，希望你能从中有所收获。好了，什么是内卷文化？我们今天在谈论什么？本质上，内卷文化教会我们的是，永远有更多——更多的钱去赚，更大的头衔或晋升，更高的高峰去攀登。它是一种持续不断地“内卷”（hustle，正如其名）的状态，或者说以完全且绝对的投入在工作中奋斗，也许没有时间休息或放松，跳过饭菜、休息时间，甚至睡眠，
expectations for our life kind of start to take form and take shape. So super interesting, very relevant and hopefully you get something out of this if these kind of topics have been something that's been on your mind recently as it has been on mine. Okay, so what's hustle culture? What are we talking about today? Essentially hustle culture teaches us that there is always more, more money to make, a bigger title or a promotion, a higher wall to climb. And it is a state of kind of constant hustling, as the name says, or working with complete and other commitment to your work, maybe with no time out or breaks, skipping meals, rest time, maybe even sleep,
以继续朝着你的职业目标努力。它真正以我们与工作的关系为中心。
to continue working towards your professional goals. It's really centered on our relationship with work. and hustle culture has emerged recently, I think, in the past 30, 20 years even, kind of as this new type of lifestyle in which work is at the center and our personal priorities and our personal lives are kind of pushed to the side. We could talk about capitalism. We could talk about all of those structures that we exist in, but sadly, this is a psychology podcast.
而内卷文化最近才出现，我认为甚至在过去的30年、20年里，它作为一种新型的生活方式出现，工作成为了中心，而我们的个人优先事项和个人生活则被推到了一边。我们可以谈论资本主义。我们可以谈论我们赖以生存的所有这些结构，但遗憾的是，这是一档心理学播客。
So we're going to be talking more about the mental element to, this kind of recent phenomenon. And we're also going to take a moment to reflect on hustle culture and what it is that we're after and how we can consciously take care of ourselves whilst we reach and carve out our ambitions. How is it that we can re-centre our aspirations and our goals and what we actually want, whether that's in our professional or personal lives, whilst also maintaining balance and incorporating other important elements that are crucial for our well-being. So I think hustle culture glorifies overworking as sort of a badge of honor. It often sets up an environment of fear, guilt and shame, especially when you don't feel like
所以我们将更多地讨论这种近期现象背后的心理因素。我们还将花一点时间反思内卷文化，反思我们到底在追求什么，以及在我们实现和开创雄心壮志的同时，如何有意识地照顾好自己。我们该如何重新以我们的抱负、目标以及我们真正想要的东西为中心，无论是我们的职业生活还是个人生活，同时保持平衡并融入对我们的福祉至关重要的其他重要元素？所以我认为内卷文化将过度工作美化为一种荣誉的徽章。它经常营造出一种恐惧、内疚和羞耻的环境，特别是当你觉得
perhaps you're running at the same pace as everyone around you. Hustle culture, this phenomenon of working harder and working more, is a social structure. It's a social phenomenon that only has power because other people buy into it. And as a collective, we start to see a trend in the way that we work now and in a way that we've been socialized to feel about work, which is that it's become a lot more important and that we should be prioritizing our professional ambitions, perhaps over our more personal ambitions. So hustle culture as a cultural and social phenomenon is really interesting. I think it's become normal because ambition has, become disguised as a lifestyle rather than as a means to an end.
也许你的步伐没有周围人那么快的时候。内卷文化，这种更努力、更多工作的现象，是一种社会结构。它是一种社会现象，之所以有力量，只是因为其他人也认同并接受了它。作为一个集体，我们开始看到我们现在的工作方式以及我们被社会化对待工作的方式出现了一种趋势，那就是它变得更加重要，我们应该优先考虑我们的职业抱负，或许甚于我们的个人抱负。因此，内卷文化作为一种文化和社会现象非常有趣。我认为它变得正常，是因为野心已经伪装成了一种生活方式，而不是达到目的的手段。
And millennials, I guess, young people in particular, perhaps if you're a recent graduate, you're particularly likely to fall into this kind of like workaholism that hustle culture perpetuates, you know, the 70, 80 hour work week and that kind of hustle mania has become something that has been drilled into us as society kind of breeds into this idea that work is more important than the other things that make life important. Maybe that's not making a lot of sense, but I think life doesn't just center around what we do to make a living. And often whilst we're making money and chasing our career goals, we can lose sight of what's important, like family and hobbies and creativity and self-care, all of which are really,
而千禧一代，我猜，特别是年轻人，如果你刚刚毕业，你特别容易陷入内卷文化所助长的那种工作狂热中，你知道的，每周70、80小时的工作周，以及那种内卷狂热已经根深蒂固地植入我们心中，因为社会潜移默化地灌输了这样一种观念：工作比生活中其他重要的事情更重要。也许这听起来不太合逻辑，但我认为生活绝不仅仅围绕着我们谋生的手段。通常，在我们赚钱和追逐职业目标的同时，我们可能会忽视真正重要的事情，比如家庭、爱好、创造力和自我关怀，所有这些对于我们的福祉都真的、真的、真的很至关重要。
really, really crucial to our well-being. Work is not our only purpose in life. And hustle culture really benefits when we forget that statement, when we forget that promise, that work is not our only purpose in life. I saw this really interesting quote around this that I think is super interesting. It was from Twitter, which is really random because I'm not traditionally on Twitter, but it says and I'm going to quote it here because I think it's a really interesting thing to talk about when we're considering the role of hustle culture in our work lives. Hustle culture takes, so hustle culture is about killing the beauty in patient discovery, the power of creative process and rewarding a focus of a mission without an expiration date.
工作并不是我们生活的唯一目的。当我们忘记这句话，当我们忘记那个承诺——工作不是我们生活的唯一目的时，内卷文化就真正从中获益了。我看到关于这一点的一个非常有趣的引言，我认为超级有趣。它来自推特，这真的很随机，因为我平时不上推特，但它是这样说的，我在这里引用它，因为我认为当我们考虑内卷文化在我们工作生活中的角色时，这是一个非常有趣的话题。内卷文化夺走了——所以内卷文化就是扼杀耐心探索中的美，扼杀创造过程的力量，并奖励那些没有截止日期的使命导向。
I thought that was super, super relevant here. rewarding focus of a mission without an expiration date. This is why hustle culture is unhealthy and unnatural. When we set goals for ourselves, the most effective type of goals we can set are those that we can easily reach and which have small incremental steps that we can follow in which to get there. That is really crucial and that's what psychology tells us about how our brain works. If you set out to run a marathon, you're not going to perhaps finish or get the time you want or get to the point where you can even run half of it.
我认为这在这里超级、超级贴切。奖励一个没有截止日期的使命导向。这就是为什么内卷文化是不健康且不自然的。当我们为自己设定目标时，我们能设定的最有效的目标类型是那些我们能够轻松达成、并且有我们可以遵循的小幅递进步骤的目标。这真的至关重要，这也是心理学告诉我们大脑运作方式的原因。如果你出发去跑马拉松，你可能无法完成，或者无法获得你想要的时间，甚至无法到达你能跑完其中一半的程度。
If in the back of your mind is I have to run 42 kilometres. My goal is to run a marathon. It's a marathon. It's a marathon. No, the way that we can achieve goals such as the marathon example is by breaking them up into smaller components that we can work towards. For example, you know, let me finish this next 5K and then it's a water break and then after 5K I'll get to 10 and then I'm only a quarter of the way there.
如果你的脑海深处想着：我必须跑42公里。我的目标是跑马拉松。这是一场马拉松。这是一场马拉松。不，我们实现诸如马拉松这样的目标的方法是将它们分解为我们可以努力实现的更小的组成部分。例如，你知道的，让我跑完接下来的5公里，然后休息喝水，跑完5公里后我跑到10公里，然后我才完成了四分之一。
Small incremental steps and small incremental goals are the most successful way to kind of reach our ambitions. Now let's put that in the context of hustle culture and that quote I read. Hustle culture does not see life and our goals and our ambitions in that light. it is about this constant striving and pushing and working for more and that more is not always tangible it's not always obvious to us exactly what we're working towards and our goals are kind of subsumed by an ideology of just working for the sake of it and for the image of being devoted and being and pushing yourself to the limits which is entirely unhealthy and if you're someone who
小幅递进的步骤和小幅递进的目标是我们实现雄心壮志最成功的方式。现在让我们把它放在内卷文化和那句我读过的引言的背景下。内卷文化并没有以这种眼光看待生活、我们的目标和雄心。它关乎这种不断地奋斗、推动和为更多而工作，而“更多”并不总是触手可及的，我们并不总是清楚我们到底在朝着什么目标努力，我们的目标被仅仅为了工作而工作以及表现得专注、将自己推向极限的形象的意识形态所吞噬，这完全是不健康的。如果你是那种
in your professional life, you have very serious goals. This idea that you just need to be constantly pushing and pushing and pushing and striving towards us and setting unnatural limits for yourself and unhealthy boundaries isn't actually going to allow you to, you know, reach those certain marks and goals and ambitions that you've set for yourself because there is no incremental goal building inside. Hustle culture is just this sense, this all-encompassing sense of work. But working for what? That is the real question. And we're seeing people, perhaps like you and I, in our 20s, continually being consumed with just the idea of our career as the sole pillar of our identity.
在职业生涯中，你有非常严肃的目标的人。这种“你只需要不断推动、推动、推动、朝着这个目标奋斗，为自己设定不自然的界限和不健康的边界”的想法，实际上并不能让你真正实现你为自己设定的那些特定目标和雄心，因为其中没有内在的渐进式目标建立。内卷文化只是一种感觉，一种包罗万象的工作感。但是为了什么工作？这才是真正的问题。我们看到人们，也许就像你和我一样，在我们二十多岁的时候，不断地被这样一种观念所吞噬：我们的职业是我们身份的唯一支柱。
And either pretending or genuinely believing that this is a satisfying and happy way to go about life, despite the fact that within those broader ambitions that you might set for yourself, you don't actually have time to sit back and consider exactly what you're working towards. What are those incremental goals? What are those small things that would make your life more meaningful and more purposeful in the short term? I think fundamentally hustle culture and the hustle culture we see in this day and age is about work dominating your time in such an unnatural way that we have no time to actually live our lives and experience the beautiful things that bring a sense of actual purpose.
并且要么假装，要么真诚地相信这是一种令人满意且快乐的生活方式，尽管在为你自己设定的那些更广泛的雄心壮志中，你实际上并没有时间坐下来思考你到底在为什么努力。那些渐进的目标是什么？那些能让你的生活在短期内变得更有意义、更有目的的小事情是什么？我认为从根本上说，内卷文化和我们在这个时代看到的内卷文化，关乎工作以一种如此不自然的方式主宰你的时间，以至于我们没有时间真正去生活，去体验那些带来真正目的感的 maravilhosa（美妙）事物。
And it has pretty severe impacts on our mental health. If you're pursuing a 70, 80 hour work week, especially if it's for image-based purposes, rather than for achieving a genuine goal that you might have, it's likely that you're going to reach the end of your tether a lot sooner than if you dialed it back and took your time and went slowly about how you approach your career and your professional life. Hustle culture, this idea of working really hard,
它对我们的心理健康产生了相当严重的影响。如果你在追求每周70、80小时的工作周，特别是如果这是为了形象的目的，而不是为了实现你可能拥有的真正目标，那么与你放慢脚步、从容不迫地对待你的职业和职业生活相比，你很可能会更快地筋疲力尽。内卷文化，这种努力工作的观念，
leads us to believe that our worth is only limited to how productive we are, to how much we produce, the amount of work we put out. Hustle culture teaches us that the thing that is most important about our identity and our self-concept is our outputs, is what we produce. And we know that that is not the case. We've talked about this on the podcast before, but our self-concept is not one-dimensional. The way that we see ourselves and the way that we view ourselves as individuals and what is important is not one-dimensional. It's multifaceted and it is defined and created and built by many different elements.
让我们相信，我们的价值仅限于我们的生产力，限于我们产出多少，限于我们投入的工作量。内卷文化教会我们，关于我们的身份和自我概念最重要的事情是我们的产出，是我们生产了什么。我们知道事实并非如此。我们以前在播客中谈论过这一点，但我们的自我概念不是单维度的。我们看待自己的方式、我们作为个体看待自己的方式以及什么才是重要的，都不是单维度的。它是多面性的，是由许多不同的元素定义、创造和构建的。
If we only focus on one element of that equation and one element of our self-concept, the rest of the these important things and these important pillars like family like hobbies like creativity like passion those things fall away and you end up becoming um i would say quite shallow and you feel quite unsatisfied with your life that is i think the massive problem with hustle culture it views it allows us to view ourselves as the sum of our output right rather than as a product of our inputs and a product of the things that we choose to prioritize within ourselves. Work is one element of a healthy self-concept. We spend a lot of time during our lives, if you're one of the lucky ones, and this doesn't apply to you. Congratulations,
如果我们只关注这个方程式中的一个元素和我们自我概念的一个元素，其余这些重要的东西和重要的支柱，比如家庭、爱好、创造力、激情，这些东西就会消失，最终你会变得——我会说——相当肤浅，并且对你的生活感到相当不满意。我认为这是内卷文化巨大的问题所在。它让我们将自己视为产出的总和，对吧？而不是将自己视为输入的产物，以及我们选择在自己身上优先考虑的事物的产物。工作是健康自我概念的一个要素。我们在生活中花费了大量时间，如果你是幸运儿之一，而这不适用于你，恭喜你，
but for the majority of people, we spend, you know, eight hours, nine hours a day, five days a week, producing things for others, producing things for the company we work for, or for the organization we work for, or for the institutions we work for. Work is an important element of life. We're not going to disregard that, and, you know, I'm not going to push this philosophy that we all need to quit our jobs and live in the forest. Work is really important. But if it begins to subsume the other things, the outcome of that is not going to be entirely healthy or fulfilling. There are a other elements of our lives which aren't focused on output which are equally important. Our familial and our personal relationships don't necessarily have the same tangible product
但对于大多数人来说，我们花八小时、九小时一天，一周五天，为他人生产东西，为我们工作的公司生产东西，或者为我们工作的组织生产东西，或者为我们工作的机构生产东西。工作是生活的一个重要元素。我们不会忽视这一点，而且（你知道的）我也不会推销这种哲学，即我们都需要辞职去森林里生活。工作真的很重要。但如果它开始吞噬其他事情，其结果将不会完全健康或令人满意。我们的生活中还有其他元素不专注于产出，但同样重要。我们的家庭和个人关系不一定像我们的工作生活那样具有相同的有形产出，但它们同样重要。
associated with them as our work lives do, but they're equally important. The same thing can be said about our hobbies or our creative outlets. You know, if you play sport on the weekend that might not necessarily have a productive output, but it really contributes to your overall sense of self and our well-being. Hustle culture and this ideology of working hard, of pushing yourself, of letting your professional life consume you, puts all of those other elements and facets of your identity at risk if you're not paying attention. The other kind of outcomes of hustle culture are perhaps more physiological and physical. So if you're working really hard, if you're obsessed with this image of being a hard worker, it can lead to lifestyle changes that have pretty
我们的爱好或创意发泄口也是如此。你知道的，如果你在周末进行体育运动，这可能不一定有生产性的产出，但它确实有助于你整体的自我感和福祉。内卷文化和这种努力工作、逼迫自己、让职业生活吞噬你的意识形态，如果不加注意，会将你身份的所有其他元素和方面置于危险之中。内卷文化的其他某种结果也许更加生理和身体化。所以如果你真的很努力工作，如果你痴迷于成为一个努力工作者的形象，这会导致生活方式的改变，对我们的心理健康产生相当负面的影响，比如不吃饭、不给自己留出休息、睡觉或社交的时间。
negative impacts on our mental health, things like skipping meals, not allowing yourself time for rest or for sleep or to socialise. And it creates a toxic environment that pressures you to work constantly and makes you feel like you can never say no. It doesn't allow for the establishment of healthy boundaries. And the result of all of the these kind of lifestyle changes, this pressure on our ability to say no, this pressure on our boundaries and our expectations for our lives results often in burnout. And burnout as a result of working really hard has not only short-term impacts on our general state of mental well-being, but also on your long-term health. The experience of your health or the state of your health in a
它创造了一个有毒的环境，迫使你不断工作，让你觉得自己永远不能说“不”。它不允许建立健康的边界。所有这些生活方式改变的结果，这种对我们说“不”能力的压力，这种对我们边界和生活期望的压力，往往会导致职业倦怠。而作为努力工作结果的职业倦怠，不仅对我们的一般心理健康状态产生短期影响，还会对我们的长期健康产生影响。你此时的健康体验或健康状态
moment might feel inconsequential, but especially when we're young and we're in our formative years and we're in our 20s, the pressure you put on your mind and your body, you know, because of your career or because of your work life, will have long-term impacts on you physically. And burnout is just one of those components. Okay, we've been pretty damning of hustle culture and we've been pretty damning of the pressure to, you know, make your professional in your work life, the center of your self-concept. and your existence, but let's talk about some of the consequences for your psychological well-being and your mental state. Burnout. Burnout is this other topic I really wanted to bring into this discussion.
可能会觉得微不足道，但特别是当我们年轻、处于形成期、处于二十多岁的时候，由于你的职业或工作生活而施加在你的心智和身体上的压力，将在生理上对你产生长期影响。而职业倦怠只是其中的一个组成部分。好了，我们已经对内卷文化进行了相当严厉的谴责，我们也对那种将职业和工作生活作为自我概念中心和生存中心的压力进行了相当严厉的谴责，但让我们来谈谈对你的心理福祉和精神状态的一些后果。职业倦怠。职业倦怠是我真正想引入这场讨论的另一个话题。
We hear a lot about it. I think burnout is a phrase that is pretty common in most corporate lifestyles at uni for people who are, you know, really being forced into a lifestyle that demands a lot of your time, either because of your professional aspirations or even some of your personal aspirations, burnout can come as a result of many different pressures acting on someone at once. It is a state of complete mental, physical and emotional exhaustion. I want to state this and I want to make a little disclaimer here. Often people equate burnout with stress. The two are not the same.
我们听到很多关于它的讨论。我认为职业倦怠是一个在大多数公司生活中相当普遍的词汇，在大学里，对于那些（你知道的）真正被迫陷入一种需要你大量时间的生活方式的人来说，无论是由于你的职业抱负还是甚至是你的某些个人抱负，职业倦怠都可能是对一个人同时起作用的多种不同压力的结果。这是一种精神、身体和情感完全耗尽的状态。我想说明这一点，我想在这里做一个小小的免责声明。人们通常将职业倦怠与压力等同起来。这两者并不相同。
you can experience moments of stress and it's very easy to bounce back from them you know you've got an upcoming deadline at uni or at work it's very normal to feel stressed about that because of time pressures and other factors that are contributing to that stress and burnout though are completely different burnout like I said is it is an ongoing state of exhaustion rather than a momentary or short-lived period of heightened anxiety. So with stress, you might be overly engaged and more worried and anxious and feel irritable and a sense of urgency and a sense of energy. But with burnout, it's very different. Burnout is different from stress because stress is often associated with high levels of energy, high levels of excitement and the arousal of our central nervous system.
你可以经历压力的时刻，而且很容易从中恢复过来，你知道的，你在大学或工作中有即将到来的截止日期，因为时间压力和其他促成这种压力的因素，对这种事情感到压力是非常正常的。然而，压力和职业倦怠是完全不同的。职业倦怠，就像我说的，是一种持续的精疲力竭状态，而不是短暂的或短命的高度焦虑期。因此，有了压力，你可能会过度参与、更加担忧和焦虑、感到烦躁、有紧迫感和能量感。但职业倦怠非常不同。职业倦怠不同于压力，因为压力通常与高水平的能量、高水平的兴奋以及中枢神经系统的唤醒有关。
whereas burnout is the stage that comes after an elongated period of stress. And it's characterized by complete disinterest, disengagement, sense of feeling numb and blunted emotions, negative, cynical, catastrophic thinking, difficulty concentrating and paying attention, difficulty sleeping, rather than a sense of kind of heightened excitement. So stress and prolonged stress, is what contributes to burnout, but they're very, very different concepts. And that's something I really want to kind of stress for people who might be listening. Because a big sign of burnout and a big warning sign of burnout is heaps of periods of stress
而职业倦怠是经历了一段漫长的压力期之后出现的阶段。其特点是完全失去兴趣、失去参与感、感到麻木和情绪迟钝、消极、愤世嫉俗、灾难性思维、难以集中注意力和注意力不集中、难以入睡，而不是那种高度兴奋感。因此，压力和长期压力是导致职业倦怠的原因，但它们是非常、非常不同的概念。这也是我真正想向可能在听的听众强调的一点。因为职业倦怠的一个巨大信号和职业倦怠的一个巨大警告信号是大量时期的压力
that are going to contribute to a state of mental and physical exhaustion. So there is a reason that this happens. There's a reason that we reach a state of feeling completely numb and completely burnt out and unable to function. When we are experiencing periods of heightened anxiety, this puts pressure on our central nervous system and on our body. So we can think about this from a really simplistic biological sense. you've got you know something coming up at work something that's really stressing you out upcoming exam period something along those lines in response to that your brain and your body identifies a threat it identifies something um that your mind and your body and you as a person are going
这将导致精神和身体精疲力竭的状态。所以发生这种情况是有原因的。我们达到一种感到完全麻木、完全精疲力竭且无法运作的状态是有原因的。当我们经历高度焦虑期时，这会对我们的中枢神经系统和身体施加压力。所以我们可以从一个非常简单的生物学意义来思考这一点。你遇到了——你知道的——工作中即将发生的事情，真正让你感到压力的事情，即将到来的考试期，诸如此类的事情。作为对此的回应，你的大脑和身体识别出一个威胁，它识别出一些——
to need to overcome so the way that it would traditionally the way that our brain would normally see a threat like that is to increase our body's capacity to respond in a fast and efficient manner. And the way that it does that is by flooding our body with a bunch of chemicals and neurotransmitters which heighten our systems, which heighten our senses, so that this upcoming, I don't know, stressful event, this upcoming, you know, almost danger or urgent kind of situation can be dealt with. If you think about, I don't know, walking into an exam and getting that, you know, racing heart rate,
你的心智和身体以及作为个人的你需要克服的东西。因此，它传统上的方式——我们的大脑通常看待这种威胁的方式，是提高我们身体快速有效反应的能力。而它做到这一点的方式是用一束化学物质和神经递质充斥我们的身体，这些物质会提高我们的系统，提高我们的感官，以便能够应对即将到来的——我不知道——压力事件，这个即将到来的——你知道的——几乎是危险或紧急的情况。如果你想想——我不知道——走进考场并感受到那种狂跳的心率，
feeling like your brain is jittery, that you literally can't write the words fast enough, the time is passing really quickly or perhaps really slowly, this altered sense of time, this heightened sense of focus, that is your body responding to the neurotransmitters and the chemicals like noraphenephrine and adrenaline that our body releases when it feels that it's going to have to respond very actively and acutely to a stressful situation. So that is great. That reaction is exactly what we want our body to do. If there is a threat or if there's something that we are feeling that we're going to need more
感觉你的大脑在颤抖，你简直无法足够快地写下文字，时间流逝得非常快，或者也许非常慢，这种对时间的改变感，这种高度的专注感，这就是你的身体对神经递质和化学物质（如去甲肾上腺素和肾上腺素）的反应，当我们感觉到我们将不得不非常积极和急切地应对压力情境时，我们的身体会释放这些物质。所以这很好。这种反应正是我们希望我们的身体做出的反应。如果存在威胁，或者如果我们感觉到我们需要更多的
resources to deal with, we want our body to respond appropriately. We perhaps want to be able to focus better. We want to be able to react quicker to prompts and to things in our environment that might be causing us anxiety or causing us stress. That is the thing that our body has, you know, learnt how to do and has been built to do over generations and generations of development and of growth and of survival. But those periods of heightened cortisol and noradrenaline and noropenephrine levels,
资源来应对，我们希望我们的身体做出适当的反应。也许我们希望能够更好地集中注意力。我们希望能够对环境中可能引起我们焦虑或压力的提示和事情做出更快的反应。这就是我们的身体——你知道的——世世代代的发展、成长和生存中学会做的和被构建要做的事情。但是那些处于高度皮质醇、去甲肾上腺素和去甲肾上腺素水平的时期，
they have consequences for our bodies. our bodies are not naturally meant to be in a state of heightened arousal and anxiety for extended periods of time, nor are they meant to have back-to-back periods of this flooding and release of energy into our body and into our cells and into our blood and into our systems. So if you are experiencing a lot of these small periodic moments of intense arousal and intense stress back-to-back, what happens is that the levels of cortisol in your body begin to rise. Cortisol has a great, great function, like I said, it's really important for allowing us to respond to immediate kind of dangers in our environment
它们对我们的身体有后果。我们的身体天生不应该长时间处于高度唤醒和焦虑的状态，也不应该经历这种能量释放到我们身体、细胞、血液和系统中的背靠背时期。因此，如果你正在经历很多这种小的、周期性的强烈唤醒和背靠背的强烈压力时刻，会发生什么呢？那就是你体内的皮质醇水平开始上升。皮质醇有一个非常、非常好的功能，就像我说的，它对于让我们能够应对环境中的即时危险真的很重要，
or to respond efficiently to, you know, long-term things that are threatening our state of equilibrium. But if it is in our bloodstream perpetually or for too long, it does start to have pretty negative consequences. Particularly one of the main things that we will see, and this is the reason why we experience burnout, if the grind and hustle culture has been really forcing us to work hard for a little while, what we'll see is our immune system start to go down and start to deplete our immune response, begin to become weaker.
或者有效地应对威胁我们平衡状态的长期事情。但如果它永远存在于我们的血液中或者时间太长，它确实开始产生相当负面的后果。特别是我们将看到的主要事情之一——这也是我们经历职业倦怠的原因，如果内卷文化一直在强迫我们努力工作一段时间，我们将看到我们的免疫系统开始下降并开始消耗我们的免疫反应，开始变得更弱。
you might begin to see that you're getting more acne or you're having changes in appetite, that if you know you have a cut on your arm or, you know, a cut on your body, it's taking longer to heal. If you're a woman, your periods or your menstrual cycle starts to become more irregular. And that is because of those long-term effects of cortisol. Cortisol, when it's been in our body too long, when we have excessive amounts, begins to have negative impacts on our physical well-being. It's no longer just a mental thing. It's no longer that your body and your brain is responding to things in your immediate environment.
你可能会开始发现你长了更多的痤疮，或者你的食欲发生了变化，如果你——你知道的——你的胳膊上有个伤口，或者——你知道的——你身体上有个伤口，它需要更长的时间才能愈合。如果你是女性，你的经期或月经周期开始变得更加不规律。这是因为皮质醇的长期影响。皮质醇，当它在我们的身体里停留太久，当我们有过量的量时，开始对我们的身体福祉产生负面影响。这不再只是一件精神上的事情。这不再是你的身体和大脑对你即时环境中的事情做出反应。
It now becomes more prominent and more significant on a more physiological and biological level. Like I said, you can see a lot of these physical impacts, but the one thing that it does, which links back to this idea, of burnout is that it exhausts your body. Your body is being put under pressure, not by a physical or external stimulus, not by, you know, doing excessive exercise or being forced through a physically demanding situation, but it's being put under pressure internally. Cortisol, the way that it's released and the way that it acts on our body activates our flight or fight systems. This prepares your muscles, it prepares your mind to, you know, be ready for danger. But if that, those signals are being sent for too long, we begin to feel exhaustion. You begin to, you know, get sick easier and all of
它现在在一个更具生理和生物学的层面上变得更加突出和重要。就像我说的，你可以看到很多这些身体影响，但它确实做的一件事——这又回到了这个想法——职业倦怠，就是它耗尽了你的身体。你的身体承受着压力，不是通过身体或外部刺激，不是通过——你知道的——进行过度的锻炼或被迫经历体力要求的境况，而是它在内部承受着压力。皮质醇，它的释放方式以及它对我们身体的作用，激活了我们的战斗或逃跑系统。这让你的肌肉做好准备，让你的心智做好准备——你知道的——为危险做好准备。但如果那些信号发送的时间太长，我们就会开始感到精疲力竭。你开始——你知道的——更容易生病以及所有
those other symptoms that we were explaining. And it leads to burnout. Your body reaches a state of complete internal physical exhaustion and it can no longer function. It breaks down. It breaks down. It breaks down. of equilibrium and sense of stability within your body, your health, begins to feel the toll of excessive stress and excessive pressure that's been put on your mind and your body and your overall sense of well-being. So this is what burnout is. That is the biological basis of burnout. Periods of intense stress and long periods, repeated periods of intense stress, result in hormonal and neural imbalances within our body. that places internal pressure on our systems and causes us to reach a state of exhaustion.
我们一直在解释的其他症状。并且它会导致职业倦怠。你的身体达到了完全内部身体精疲力竭的状态，它无法再运作了。它崩溃了。它崩溃了。它崩溃了。平衡状态和身体内的稳定感，你的健康开始感受到施加在你的心智、身体和整体福祉感上的过度压力和过度压力的代价。所以这就是职业倦怠。这就是职业倦怠的生物学基础。强烈压力的时期和长期、重复的强烈压力时期，导致我们体内的荷尔蒙和神经失调。这给我们的系统施加了内部压力，并导致我们达到精疲力竭的状态。
Okay, let's talk about that a little bit more. Say that you're at that state of being incredibly burnt out. I'm sure that we all have felt this, have all experienced this. Maybe it was when you were doing your final exams for school or, like I said, you've got a lot of deadlines coming up for uni or for work. and even a lot of pressure in your personal life. I think that's the other important thing is that work and academic pressures don't occur in a vacuum. You know, if you've got a lot of going on at work, it's not like the rest of your life is put on pause.
好吧，让我们再多谈谈这一点。假设你处于那种难以置信地精疲力竭的状态。我确信我们所有人都感受过这一点，都经历过这一点。也许是在你期末考试的时候，或者像我说的，你有很多即将到来的大学或工作的截止日期。甚至在你的个人生活中也有很大的压力。我认为另一个重要的事情是，工作和学术压力并非发生在真空中。你知道的，如果你在工作中有太多事情要做，并不是说你生活的其余部分被暂停了。
You'll also have personal problems and, you know, personal dramas or things that you need to deal with. You've got, you know, all of these other elements such as what's going on in the world, which will be contributing to that exhaustion and that stress and that pressure that's being put on your body. So what do you do? What do we do? Burnout if it's somewhat inevitable or if it's going to happen at times. How do we create an environment and create patterns and healthy habits that allow us to bounce back and allow us to get back to a point of equilibrium and of normal functioning. So the main thing that we need to address is perhaps reducing that stress to begin with. Let's reduce the trigger for this excessive cortisol level and this excessive exhaustion.
你还会有个人问题和——你知道的——个人戏剧或你需要处理的事情。你拥有——你知道的——所有这些其他元素，例如世界上正在发生的事情，这些都将促成那种精疲力竭、压力以及施加在你身体上的压力。那么你该怎么办？我们该怎么办？职业倦怠如果多少是不可避免的，或者有时会发生。我们如何创造一个环境、创造模式和健康习惯，使我们能够反弹并回到平衡和正常运作的点？我们需要解决的主要事情也许是首先减少这种压力。让我们减少这种过量皮质醇水平和过量精疲力竭的触发因素。
Being able to identify what is causing you to feel burnt out, whether that be work or academic pressures is crucial for putting yourself back on the right pathway and reducing over. levels of exhaustion and stress that are occurring in your life. So is there something that can be done to reduce the pressure and reduce the things and the number of items that are kind of stacking up on your plate? If the answer is yes, fantastic. Great. If you can do something about it, if you can minimize the amount of pressure and external
能够识别是什么导致你感到精疲力竭，无论是工作还是学术压力，对于让自己回到正确的道路上以及减少过度因素至关重要。你生活中的精疲力竭和压力水平正在发生。那么，有什么可以做来减少压力并减少那些堆在你盘子里的东西和事情的数量吗？如果答案是肯定的，太棒了。太好了。如果你能对此做些什么，如果你能将压力和外部压力降到最低
pressure, you're feeling on yourself, that is fabulous. Congratulations. But there are other things that need to be done. and if that's perhaps not the case and not something that you can do in that moment, there are lifestyle changes and choices and behavioural patterns and modifiable lifestyle patterns that you can make and changes that you can make that reduce the impact of cortisol on your body. The first thing to do, and I think one of the primary things that's often suggested, is to focus on diet, sleep and exercise.
你对自己的要求很高，这很棒，恭喜你。但还有其他事情需要完成。如果情况并非如此，或者你在当时无法做到这一点，你可以做出一些生活方式的改变、选择、行为模式以及可调整的生活方式模式，这些改变和选择可以减少皮质醇对你身体的影响。首先要做的事情，也是经常被建议的首要事情之一，就是关注饮食、睡眠和运动。
these are three ways that we are able to kind of control the reactions and the kind of subconscious beyond our control reactions that are occurring in our body making sure you're getting you know those eight hours eating healthy foods and good foods for you hydrating so that your body has all of the resources that it needs to respond properly to stress in your environment is crucial. And exercise. That is one of the main ways that we can release pent up cortisol and adrenaline levels within our body by giving it an actual outlet and a kind of way to release all of that energy that's within our body, putting pressure on us internally. It's very interesting because one of the suggestions that a psychologist might give to you or a doctor might give to you
这是我们能够控制身体中发生的各种反应以及某种超出我们控制的潜意识反应的三种方式。确保你有那八个小时的睡眠，吃健康的食物，吃对你有益的食物，多喝水，以便你的身体拥有对环境中的压力做出正确反应所需的所有资源，这是至关重要的。还有运动。这是我们释放体内积聚的皮质醇和肾上腺素水平的主要方法之一，通过给它一个实际的宣泄口以及一种释放体内所有能量的方式，这些能量正在对我们内部施加压力。这非常有趣，因为心理学家或医生可能会给你的建议之一是
if you're having a panic attack, is to engage in excessive exercise because that is the best way to release, you know, pent up energy and chemical reactions in your body. Cortisol is looking to respond to something in our environment. So by exercising regularly, we're giving it that thing that it needs to respond to. We're giving it its outlet. And that really allows us to kind of alleviate the pressure that it's putting on our internal systems. I think there's other things that can also really contribute to reducing the level of burnout and exhaustion and stress we might feel.
如果你正在经历恐慌发作，就要进行过度的运动，因为这是释放体内积聚的能量和化学反应的最佳方式。皮质醇希望对我们环境中的某种事物作出反应。因此，通过定期运动，我们给了它需要反应的事物。我们给了它一个宣泄口。这确实能让我们减轻它对我们内部系统施加的压力。我认为还有其他事情也可以真正有助于减少我们可能感受到的职业倦怠、精疲力竭和压力的程度。
And that's making sure that we prioritize the things that we know make us feel well. This comes back to hustle culture. If your work and your professional life are the pillar around which everything else stands, it's very likely that you're probably not putting in enough energy and effort into the things that genuinely bring you a sense of purpose and bring you a sense of happiness and goodness. So re-centering your life along kind of the, yeah, re-centering your life along the things that are important greatly reduces the likelihood that we are going to reach a state where our body is going to force us to take a break, when our body is going to physically tell us to stop.
那就是确保我们优先考虑那些我们知道能让我们感觉良好的事情。这就回到了内卷文化。如果你的工作和职业生活是你赖以支撑一切的支柱，那么你很可能没有投入足够的精力和努力去追求那些真正能带给你使命感、幸福感和美好感的事物。因此，重新以那些重要的事情为中心来调整你的生活，会大大降低我们陷入这样一种状态的可能性：我们的身体强迫我们休息，我们的身体物理性地告诉我们停下来。
One way that I find this is really useful, one way that I find that's really useful, like a habit and a pattern that I get into, is non-negotiables in my life. Things and things that I plan each week that have nothing to do with work, have nothing to do with my professional output that are non-negotiable to me,
我发现这非常有用的一种方法，我发现非常有用的一种习惯和模式，就是我生活中的“不容妥协事项”。我每周计划的那些与工作无关的事情，与我的职业产出无关的事情，对我来说是不容妥协的，
no matter how much needs to be done, you know, within my job, no matter how much people are asking of me, these are things that I do not compromise on. And they're things that I find personally fulfilling. One of them is the podcast. Another one is rock climbing or having a physical outlet that I do every single week, every Wednesday, I go rock climbing. And at 7.30, no matter what else is going on, even if someone's asked me to work late, that's a non-negotiable for me. I will clock off and I will go and do it. it because that's important for creating balance in my life, seeing friends regularly as well.
无论我的工作中有多少事情需要完成，无论人们对我有多少要求，这些都是我绝不妥协的事情。而且这些都是我个人觉得很有成就感的事情。其中之一就是播客。另一个是攀岩，或者进行每周都会做的体能锻炼，每周三我去攀岩。在七点半，无论发生什么事，即使有人要求我加班，对对我来说也是不可妥协的。我会打卡下班去参加，因为这对于在我的生活中创造平衡很重要，定期见朋友也很重要。
If, you know, I've gone a few days without having social contact beyond my work life or beyond the people that I kind of, I'm surrounded by at work, although they're lovely, you know, I do want to have conversations and see people that have nothing to do with what I do from, you know, 9 a.m. to 5 p.m. So that's really important as well. Making time to connect with family and with friends is a great way to avoid getting to a point of mental exhaustion where like I said, your body is going to force you to take a break. In this day and age with our changing attitudes and cultural attitudes around the role of our professional work life in our broader existence and some broader self-concept, it is really easy to buy into hustle culture and to buy into the
如果我知道，我已经好几天没有进行超越工作生活或超越我周围那些人的社交接触了，虽然他们在工作之余很可爱，但我确实想和那些与我朝九晚五的工作无关的人聊天、见面。所以这同样非常重要。腾出时间与家人和朋友联系，是避免达到精神崩溃边缘的好方法，正如我所说，你的身体会强迫你休息。在这个时代，随着我们对职业工作在我们更广泛生存中的角色以及更广泛的自我概念的态度和文化态度的变化，人们很容易接受内卷文化，接受这种
idea that the only way to get ahead is to work on reasonable hours and sacrifice the important parts and meaningful elements of our life. I don't think that's the case. I think it's possible to do well in your career and to have professional aspirations whilst still remaining focused and clear and centred on what is really, really important. I think maintaining those healthy boundaries around what's important to you and what's a non-negotiable in your life really also helps us avoid that kind of pattern of exhaustion and stress and burnout that we've talked about. So I hope that this episode has kind of shed a bit of light. It was a bit of a ramble.
观点：出人头地的唯一方法就是工作不合理的时间，并牺牲我们生活中重要且有意义的元素。我不这么认为。我认为，在事业上做得很好并拥有职业抱负的同时，依然能够保持专注、清晰和以真正重要的事情为中心，是完全可能的。我认为，在对你重要的事情以及你生活中的“不容妥协事项”周围保持这些健康的界限，确实也有助于我们避免前面讨论过的那种精疲力竭、压力和职业倦怠的模式。所以我希望这一集能带来一些启示。这有点像漫无边际的闲聊。
I think it was just something I really wanted to discuss on the podcast this week and just kind of dump my thoughts and my knowledge out upon all of you. So hopefully you got something out of it if you're experiencing something similar, if you're kind of stuck in the corporate way of thinking and this day and ages way of thinking around work. Take a step back and make sure that what you're doing in your life aligns with what you actually want. It's very easy to be passive and to fall into the social and cultural and professional expectations that our jobs and our community and our society demands of us. But taking time to really think about what is going to make your life meaningful for you will inevitably have amazing benefits for your mental health, your physical health, and your long-term well-being, and probably even benefits for your career in the long-term.
我想这只是我本周真的很想在播客上讨论的事情，只是想把我的想法和知识倾倒给大家。所以希望如果你正在经历类似的事情，如果你有点陷入公司思维和当今时代的思考方式中，你能从中获得一些收获。退一步讲，确保你生活中所做的事情符合你的真实意愿。人们很容易变得被动，陷入我们的工作、社区和我们社会对我们要求的社会、文化和职业期望中。但是花时间真正思考什么会让你的生活对你来说变得有意义，不可避免地会对你的心理健康、身体健康和长期福祉带来惊人的好处，从长远来看，甚至可能对你的职业生涯有益。
You know, when your body is forcing you to take a break, it's really, you know, not going to take no for an answer. And no matter what deadlines you have on, you're not going to be able to push through that. So hopefully this has been a nice reminder on the importance of balance. And thank you, as always, for listening. If you've enjoyed this episode and you feel called to please leave a review or a five-star rating on Apple Podcasts or Spotify, wherever you're listening right now, it really does help the podcast grow. And if you're interested in paid subscriber content, like I said, that's now available.
你知道，当你的身体强迫你休息时，它真的不会接受“不”作为答案。无论你有什么截止日期，你都无法硬撑过去。所以希望这能成为一个很好的提醒，提醒我们平衡的重要性。一如既往，谢谢你们的收听。如果你喜欢这一集，并且愿意的话，请在苹果播客、Spotify或你现在收听的任何地方留下评论或五星好评，这确实对播客的发展有很大帮助。如果你对付费订阅内容感兴趣，正如我所说，现在已经可以收听了。
So get onto it if you feel the need. If you want to listen to more of my voice, maybe not. Yeah, there's links somewhere. I'm sure you can figure it out. And as always, thank you for listening. I will be back next week. Don't know what we're talking about yet. But if you have suggestions, reach out on Instagram and I'll get to it.
所以有需要的话就去看看吧。如果你想听更多我的声音，也许不用。好吧，某处有链接。我相信你能找到它。一如既往，谢谢你们的收听。我下周还会回来。还不知道我们要聊什么。但如果你有什么建议，可以在Instagram上联系我，我会去做的。
Thank you so much. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host, Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to,
非常感谢。嘿，最近怎么样，各位？你们正在收听由你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人凯尔·盖姆斯带来的《艰难学习》。这个空间关乎黑人男性的经历，进行在任何地方都不太安全但确实需要的坦诚对话，而你正在与一位深谙此道的持证专业人士进行交流。有多少男人穿着盔甲？它向世界发出信号，表明你不是好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要这样做，
listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test once. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing.
在iHeart电台应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《艰难学习》。2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控是双胞胎的父亲。但这次怀孕似乎是个骗局。欧文斯女士，你伪造了这个特定的测试两次，对吗？我伪造了一次测试。这需要一大群互联网侦探来揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。
Greg, a lesbian. Michael Mancini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you
格雷格，一个女同性恋。迈克尔·曼奇尼。我的脑洞大开。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《爱情陷阱》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临后果。在iHeart电台应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《爱情陷阱》播客
get your podcasts. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side a happier,
2%。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我剖析了在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中，心理韧性、健身和建立复原力的科学。经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、
more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO% on the IHeart Radio app. Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast, guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
更有成就感、更健康的人。收听《2%》。即在iHeart电台应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《2%》。这是一个iHeart播客，保证由人类制作。这一集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。